it sure felt like a playoff game to me
last night it felt like it it sounded
like it and not just the crowd there but
it sounded like it because almost as I
said in the first hour every hit ended
with a thump and a man who personifies
that and I'm not just saying that
because he said he would call into this
show
the man who personifies that and a
perennial Pro Bowler who's on a Hall of
Fame trajectory in my mind his name is
Bobby Wagner kind enough to call it a
day after a huge Monday night victory
for the Seahawks in Santa Clara how are
you Bobby I'm doing good how are you
that's felt like a playoff game how
about you definitely play out there you
know the defense is doing great I was
making plays the crowd was loud the
energy in the building was crazy
obviously the game was crazy so I mean
it felt great now again it's just like I
said every hit seemed to end with a
thump whether it was you and your mates
or the 49ers that way as well when did
you begin to feel like it was that type
of an atmosphere in that type of game
Bobby I mean I think you do it coming
into the game see how that deepens play
seeing how we wanted to play felt like
we had it even you know a lot more
physical to kind of affect their offense
and so you know from the very beginning
we felt like we were coming out we were
going to try to hit and we went out of
here and it was kind of just you know
who was gonna hit the motion you know
it's a really fun game to play in you
know we went to overtime down to the
last you know setting so it's one of
those games you get to go remember
you know the good win for our team to go
into the bar week so you know it's one
of those games we knew like the more
physical team was gonna be the one who
went and man it was so physical for for
sure let's let's parse this out a little
bit here you had a front-row seat for
Jadeveon Clowney best game obviously
that he's had with your team many folks
are saying it may be the best game he's
had period
what what what do you think clicked for
him last night that might be repeatable
moving forward Bobby I just think he
finally got to the quarterback you know
I think you know when you watch the game
prior to it wasn't like he wasn't you
know making good booze they're doing
this is just a quarterback for getting
the ball out before he can get the sack
but he was getting a lot of QB hits and
so you know we did a pretty good job in
the back end making Garoppolo hold the
ball or allow time for the de Lima to
get there especially him you know and
and when he's in the back so all it
takes is you know one or two hits and
you you could just feel his energy fill
him you know turn it up a notch and
that's exactly where did he seem like he
was around the quarterback or hitting
the quarterback almost every play they
try to drop back and you know we were
able to get some sacks and we ever get
some fumbles create some turnovers and
that's how our defenses look Bobby
Wagner of Seattle Seahawks linebacker
just fresh off of the plane back from
Santa Clara off of a dynamite Monday
night overtime win for Seattle right
here on the Rich Eisen show do you watch
Russell from your position at all or
what are you doing when the offense is
out there on the field I know you
definitely I mean you try to go back to
the sidelines and you look over the clay
that you uh you know you had the series
that you're in but once you're done with
that you kind of get up and you want to
support their the offense and you know
you get a chance to watch Russell do
some of the bases he was doing it and
you know it's just crazy were in those
positions where its fourth quarter or
overtime we have so much confidence in
him his ability to make plays because
you know for myself the cage eight guys
has been around and seen him do it for
many years it's kind of something that
we've grown accustomed to because we
know you know how much confidence that
we have in him and so it's kind of cool
to see like the younger guys or you know
younger guys that haven't necessarily
seen it how they're you know kind of
sitting on the edge of their seats and
we're kind of you know calm because we
come because we've seen this this
picture before
well it's interesting too from my
perspective Bobby since obviously I've
been following this
since before Russell and you arrived and
now that Russell used to be the young
guy he used to be the young guy that
everybody was depending on but maybe not
as vocal as everybody else in the locker
room and representing the entire team in
a way because there were so many other
alpha males in the room I wonder what
your perspective of his change in role
or his change in anything because this
appears to be his team right now Bobby I
mean he's always been a leader he's
always gonna leave this doe he led by
led in the way that he felt was the best
and you know that's what works for us
and you know like you said we had a lot
of guys that were a little bit more
outspoken and interface bit that he may
have was but just because that was going
all doesn't mean he was doing it scenes
behind the scenes or being the leaders I
think that's wrong especially as he's
you know grown from not being as the
young guards appearance but the older
guy and you know trying to get guys to
understand what does it take to be a
championship team and you know you've
done a great job and these are the guys
that in and you know happy is our thing
and what about the fact that you Bobby
and Russell you you were drafted same
draft just one round apart that now and
you mentioned KJ right and I'm sure
there are some other guys that have been
there around for a bit but from the
legion of boom era where you went to
back-to-back Super Bowls to now the
transition appears to have been seamless
which is so rare in the NFL what what
have you been your role in and being I
guess an extension of coach Carroll's
mantra or what you believe to be a
Seahawk way in that locker room yeah I
think my role as well as KJ's and
Krusty's role is to like you said be an
extension but provide that leadership
provide that that guidance because we
kind of been through some some seasons
we have seen as well as those out there
who have season
but we always finish really really well
and so I think our job especially on my
end is to you know show the guys what it
takes to be a professional show the guys
what it takes to be a good player and
show them what in what do we do to to
get to that level what did we do to to
have the success that we were having and
especially on on my end I think a lot of
times where you come in into a new
situation and you're you know you're
seeing things I'm gone and Earl gone and
cam gone and my Bennett and cliff and so
on and so forth you sometimes feel like
you have to step in and be those guys
you're not doing you know it's just
important for me to to say wasn't always
like that Sharon what didn't just walk
into the league and he was like that it
took time for him to to turn into that
player and so you know but he put the
work in so reminding those guys to put
the work in and be the best version of
yourself and will be just fine and so we
got a great leader on on the officers
blog are great leaders on deep inside of
the ball and I thought that's why we
were able to transition as well yeah
Bobby Wagner a few more minutes left
with the Seahawks linebacker fresh off
of an overtime victory over the 49ers
handing the 49ers their first loss of
the season right here on the Rich Eisen
show you told my colleague at the NFL
Network Jim Trotter that you and KJ were
beginning to sniff out some of the
checks of Jimmy G is that correct you
know home in our cloud is so amazing and
so loud it's not always we don't always
get to hear every check that they uh
that they make but you know more on the
road is it's quieter than what the
office be able to communicate so we're
able to just kind of listening and
really get a good feel for where they
were going because this is you know one
of the harder teams when you watch them
to pick up on anything
Tennessee wise because they'll have so
many different plays they bring so many
different routes they have so many
different complimenting please
to each one of their plays that they
have but you know we felt like we were
able to to to hear him pretty well and
start getting a feel for the way the
linemen said it was a fullback with
setting and you know we feel like it
started to help us towards a you know
once we got that going the guys in the
booth for Monday night we're saying or
at least booger for sure said that Jimmy
G look rattled in the overtime would you
agree with that assessment yeah we
definitely felt like you know when you
have stink clowny had 10 hits himself I
believe when you you applying that type
of pressure on the quarterback and get
his face every every so often it makes
it hard for a quarterback to sit there
and just throw the ball you know I felt
like we did a really good job back in or
you know picking up the routes and you
know seeing where he was trying to get
the ball we had a lot of picks that we
should have had and so hopefully next
time we play we actually come down with
those all right and then just a couple
of cleanup items before I send you on
into your bye week Bobby did you bet
Laker tickets with Richard Sherman on
last night's game is that a true story
okay which we know which game then I
assume it's corny activity it's
courtside right I mean we're not messing
around here correct so you know no all
I'm saying is it's it's two guys who
negotiated their own contracts and
making a ton of money because you're
definitely not paying anybody any fees
for anything you should be that we save
you know from from agencies you
definitely yeah okay so you guys are
going to have to you're going to the
game together and you know we were huge
like a fan okay we were with them when
they wasn't doing so well and so now it
seems like you know we've been to a
couple games with you know top of the
division it's a really fun time and and
we definitely try catch again so if you
know about rivalries which you know very
well I mean you're not concerned about
the Clippers you don't want to go too
I mean Kauai is love Kauai and Paul
George criminal clip regatta they gotta
do this they got you know saying like
it's cool to got all on the town and all
that stuff but they got it they got a
16-4 at least once everybody's crowning
them before they even you know put an
82-game schedule in you know they could
go to a point out they could choke we
don't know so Lakers as we have history
of winning multiple championships so let
the Clippers win one first okay all
right I respect that certainly since
somebody who just walked it and for the
whole country can see he can talk it for
sure like that well yeah quiet why is a
quiet definitely the first night back
and I talked to that it's kind of funny
I was a on Twitter a couple weeks ago
somebody send me a picture at it I
didn't realize that I played in high
school
no kidding yeah so I'll talk to you the
pictures but yeah we were like boxing I
was boxing them out or something so it's
kind of funny you boxed up board man is
that what you're saying in high school I
don't know if you should just say that
you did get the rebound that's fine I'll
go with if I wouldn't keep you say I had
a triple-double twenty twenty or twenty
God like it I like it let's just ski
let's just keep getting bigger
last one for you were you out at the
coin toss for overtime Bobby were you
out there okay he went up by himself huh
he went up by himself for the coin toss
you do realize people think he said
tails and you got the ball awarded to
you incorrectly are you wearing that
Bobby no well I wasn't aware of it but
I'm pretty sure people try to find ways
to be mad when they lose so this go
ahead take the L will see them again and
you know make sure I guess he make sure
he's miked up when he does the coin toss
it okay if we get it to overtime and you
okay and it's double or nothing with
Richard for week 17 right maybe okay
Bobby I really appreciate you calling in
taking the time with your bye week and
then after that game like I said you're
one of my favorites and I appreciate you
doing this immensely thank you I
appreciate you having any time and I'm I
always love being honest I'm saying that
you always have a place here just like
you do in the middle of that Seahawks
defense that's Bobby Wagner linebacker
fresh off of the big win last night in
San Francisco right here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app